l und
[Musik]
Precht schönen guten Morgen Richard
guten Morgen Markus 22 Dezember Richard
du schon in
Weihnachtsstimmung nachtspodcast genau
und ich ich ich find's schön und ich
habe mich gefragt was schenken wir beide
uns eigentlich in diesem Jahr abgesehen
von der Stunde Aufmerksamkeit die wir
uns wöchentlich geben hast du schon
Geschenk für mich also eine Stunde
Aufmerksamkeit für den anderen ist ja
schon so unglaublich viel ja das stimmt
dass wir gar nicht erst versuchen über
den Umweg eines materiellen Geschenkes
ja dem anderen zum Ausdruck zu geben
dass man sich mit ihm beschäftigt
wirklich finde ich auch ich schenken ist
ja so ein so so ein zwiespeltiges aber
auch ein schönes Ding finde ich ne wenn
man sich mal mit schenken ein bisschen
beschäftigt und ich wollte heute gerne
mal mit dir über schenken reden das ja
philosophisch ein unvorstellbarreiches
Thema ist es ist es also schenken ist
wahrscheinlich etwas was Menschen schon
seit mehr als 100.000 Jahren machen dass
sie sich wechselseitig was schenken also
das fängt schon damit an dass man sich
Mahlzeiten schenkt oder sich
wechselseitig dazu einledädt dem anderen
was abgeben hat ja eine so hohe
symbolische Bedeutung dass man davon
ausgehen können das ist ganz ganz
uraltes menschliches Verhalten mhm und
wir leben zwar heute in einer modernen
Welt wo so die Austauschbeziehung des
Menschen in hohem Maße ja auch
juristisch geregelt ist ne also der
Austausch also der große Soziologe Georg
smel der vertrat die These dass aller
Verkehr unter den Menschen auf dem
Schema von Hingabe und equivalent
besteht Hingabe und equivalentab
equivalent also alles was wir tun sind
Sozi
Austauschbeziehungen ja und ich mache
etwas für dich und du bist darauf hin
gezwungen zu reagieren normalerweise
dadurch dass du irgendetwas für mich
tust also ein Äquivalent meiner Hingabe
gibst so jetzt gibt es viele Situationen
da ist das ganz sachlich ja wenn du
einen Vertrag machst ja jemand oder du
einkaufen gehst ne Ware gegen Geld so
das ist und wenn wenn du dich nicht an
die spergeln hältst ja dann kannst du
verklagt werden es gibt also ganz viele
Sachen die sind juristisch völlig klar
geregelt im Spiel von Hingabe und
Äquivalent aber es gibt ja auch viele
soziale Räume wo wir das auch machen in
Partnerschaft in Beziehung im Verhältnis
zu unseren Kindern mit unseren Freunden
und so da ist das ja nicht juristisch
klar geregelt und da wird's schwierig
weil da muss sich jeder überlegen was er
für das passende Äquivalent hält richtig
ja und da fng dam geht's richtig los
wirklich genau und wenn du dich mal
damit beschäftigst merkst du plötzlich
also Schenken von dem man ja immer sagen
würde es ist ja erstmal uneingeschränkt
schön ja so die die alte boxerweisheit
ja geben ist seliger den nehmen ja aber
die war ist es kann alles sehr schnell
sehr unselig werden wenn du wenn du ne
weil schenken so was sind meine
Möglichkeiten was macht das aber mit dem
anderen ja also fühlt der sich dann
verpflichtet mir etwas zurückzuschenken
und was wenn das nicht sagen wir mal
monetär ein einen ähnlichen Gegenwert
hat und so weiter muss der sich dann
schlecht fühl oder anders muss der mir
gegenüber dankbar sein all diese Fragen
die da plötzlich sich dran anschließen
äh das sind wirklich spannende Fragen
und das was du gerade kurz angedeutet
hast Richard das ja interessant ne das
ähm meine schenken war ja das sagen ja
auch Ethnologen das war ja sozusagen
eine überlebensversicherung letzten
Endes ne also in in früheren kleinen
Lebensgemeinschaften und ich ich kenne
das z.B aus Grönland also wenn du wenn
du der Jäger bist der jetzt rausgeht und
nichts fängt
und kommst zurück dann bist Du darauf
angewiesen dass dir der Nachbar etwas
abgibt mit anderen Worten dir etwas
schenkt du hast ja nichts
zurückzuschenken und umgekehrt habe ich
häufig gesehen wenn jemand rausgeht und
ist hat Großes Jagdglück kommt mit einer
oder sogar zwei Robben zurück dann wird
das verteilt und zwar muss muss ja er
kann das ja nicht alleine essen ja das
ist das eine also das eine ist sozusagen
der der genau der der der
die das ganz oft in mein grland Richard
nicht in Grönland stimt Grönland ja
nicht in Grönland aber wenn du den
Büffel gejagt hast ja als als nativer
Amerikaner dann dann war das natürlich
so dass du den da nicht so lange lagern
Kontest genau die Abwesenheit von
Kühlschränken ne ist sozusagen die
Voraussetzung für bedingungsloses
schenken ja so so ist das genau wo kein
Kühlschrank ist ja ist die gemeinsame
Mahlzeit wichtig ich weiß nicht ob der
Grönländer auch gerne allein ist nein
ich sag das immer meinen Vorträgen
es gibt
die Theorie aus der evolutionären
Psychologie das ist also jene
Wissenschaft die unser ganzes Verhalten
auf steinzeitliche Muster zurückführt
die Theorie dass die Geselligkeit und
Kooperation des Menschen dadurch
entstanden wäre weil niemand alleine ein
Mammut jagen kann ne also da brauchst du
mehrere die müssen sich absprechen
müssen sich koordinieren und so weiter
muss man sich gut verstehen so und das
ist ja nur die halbe Wahrheit weil ich
glaube dass die Geselligkeit und
Kooperation im gleichen Maße unter den
Menschen standen ist weil niemand
alleine ein Mammut aufessen kann ja und
jagen kann man im zweifelsit immer noch
alleine aber Mammut kann man nicht
alleine essen und deswegen macht das
Essen in Gesellschaft deutlich mehr Spaß
bis heute ja als in früheren Zeiten also
selten fühlt man sich so allein als wenn
man dauerhaft alleine essen muss du
sitzt alleine im Restaurant die Hölle ja
ja schlimm das das das will man ja gar
nicht also wie ist das denn jetzt mit
dem Grünländer mit und dem sch in
Grünland kannst du ne Essen tatsächlich
sehr lange konservieren aber auch da da
da da wird natürlich essen geteilt
überlebensversicherung ja und deswegen
ist geben und teilen ist sozusagen
lebensrettend ja ohne geben und teilen W
haben wir als Menschheit schon lange
ausgestorben und das hat sich natürlich
jetzt alles fundamental verändert und
man hat das Gefühl wenn man sich mal die
nackten Zahlen anschaut ne ich meine
schenken ist ja mittlerweile daraus ist
ja eine nicht nur eine Industrie sondern
es ist eine eine eine eine
geschenksorgie geworden also
2005 haben die Deutschen Geschenke im
Gegenwert Weihnachten ne im Gegenwert
von ungefähr glaube 80 Milliarden sich
gegenseitig geschenkt in diesem Jahr und
ist jetzt 25 ja ist nicht so lange her
mal 20 Jahre weiter bist du hoch von 80
Milliarden auf ungefähr
123 Milliarden mus mal
vorstellen aber inflationsbereinigt
wahrscheinlich die gleiche Summe meinst
du ja würde ich schätzen mal über ein
Daumen gepeilt würde ich sagen
wahrscheinlich die gleiche Summe es ist
ja nicht so als ob die Leute hier
deutlich mehr Geld in der Tasche hätten
als 2005 das würde auch jeder Ökonom
sagen inflationsbereinig hat er das
nicht aber es ist zumindestens stabil
geblieben ja ne aber für mich ist es
eher was anderes es zeigt es nicht
sozusagen dass es da auch eine soziale
Erwünschtheit gibt also offensichtlich
erwarten wir und die anderen auch von
uns dass man sie selbstverständlich
beschenkt und ich frage mich manchmal
und darüber wollte ich mich gerne mit
dir austauschen haben wir da vielleicht
was verlernt haben wir da was falsch
verstanden ich meine den ist essentiell
für unsere Gesellschaft ja so noch mal
ich habe das ja noch nicht ganz zu Ende
erzählt ne also diese simmelthese ne das
war ja auf der einen Seite klar Hingabe
und Äquivalent haben wir jetzt
verstanden im Privaten ist das man
schenkt was und der andere gibt ein
irgendeine Form der Gegengabe also das
gilt für Aufmerksamkeit das gilt für
materielle Geschenke und jetzt kommt
eine poin und die Pointe besteht darin
der der zuerst schenkt ja der hat einen
lebenslangen
Vorsprung wenn ich dir jetzt was schenke
ich ma jetzt ein völlig
überdimensioniertes du kriegst jetzt
diesmal zu Weihnachten von mir ein
spektakuläres Geschenk ein R wo du wurde
wo die wo dir im ersten Moment genau
super peinlich ist dass ich dir so ein
Geschenk mache ja und selbst wenn du
hingehen würdest und würdest du mir ein
Geschenk der gleichen Größe machen in
derselben Preiskategorie dann sind wir
nicht quit weil ich habe dir das zu
deiner völligen Verblüffung freiwillig
geschenkt und du hast mir das andere
zurückgegeben damit es nicht peinlich
ist ja das heißt diese Freiwilligkeit
die in meinem schenkakt lag die kannst
du nie mehr abarbeiten böse siehst du
das ist nicht böse das hält nach Georg
Simmel Gesellschaften zusammen man
bringt durch verschenken Menschen in
psychische Abhängigkeiten und
stabilisiert damit ein soziales Band in
der Gesellschaft weil das millionenfach
multipliziert hält Menschen zusammen das
ist diese mthese von 1907 der der tolle
Bücher was Geld auch geschrieben hat ne
eine große berühmte Philosophie des
Geldes 1900 genau das war ein Meister er
macht ganz feine Beobachtung in der
Alltagswelt ja und dann rechnet er die
so auf mikroebenen gewonnenen
Erkenntnisse auf so eine Makroebene hoch
und macht daraus eine große
soziologische Theorie und zum Thema Geld
und das einmal kurz in Klammern
einzufügen was ist sozusagen der
zentrale Gedanke rund ums Geld ja also
in meiner Formulierung aber Simmels
Gedanken Geld ist die einzige Sache
deren Qualität sich allein an der
Quantität bemisst ja ja sehr schön ja ja
und
das führt dazu dass alle anderen Werte
die mit dem Geld in Konflikt kommen ja
durch die Logik des Geldes die
quantitative Logik des Geldes irgendwann
genichtet werden das heißt also alles
ist irgendwann käuflich ist nur eine
Frage der Höhe des Preises so und jetzt
kann man sagen oh was ist das denn für
eine traurige these und er sagt ne ist
eine gute these weil vor dem Geld sind
alle gleich ja weil das Geld wird von
allen akzeptiert und der ein ig Maßstab
ist eben viel und wenig aber es ist
nicht mehr ich bin von vornehben edlen
Stande ich bin Angehöriger eine anderen
Ethnie eines anderen Geblüts und so
weiter und deswegen schafft das Geld
eine globale
einheitszivilisation und letztlich
demokratisiert ist we die alten alten
Hürden der adelswelt abschafft ja das
ist die gute Seite immer die schlechte
Seite des Geld ist unss auch allen
bekannt ne dass es irgendwann psychisch
so abhängig macht dass Menschen dann nur
noch diesen hat anerkennen und alle
anderen dafür bereit sind zu Nichten ist
ja eine sehr ambivalente Angelegenheit
er hat das nicht gewertet er ist einfach
beschrieben und muss sagen so ist es
auch gekommen ja spannend gibt gibt
diesen schönen Satz von Niklas Lummer ne
Weihnachten ist eine wechselseitige
Besteuerung zunsten des Handels mhm das
ist sehr hübsch ja das ist sehr hübsch
ja ich könnte von von von Niklas Luhmann
bislang als als Bomont für dir nicht so
berühmt war ja äh also großer Soziologe
Bielefeld und so weiter den Satz Ehen
werden im Himmel gestiftet und auf
Autositzen
geschieden warum auf Autos sitzen ich
weiß nicht aber so stellte er sich
wahrscheinlich ein unromantisches Ende
vor
ja super aber noch mal zurück zum
Schenken ne Wilhelm Schmied
den du natürlich kennst und der über den
wir schon paar mal hier gesprochen haben
der ja immer so kleine feine Büchlein
schreibt unter anderem auch über den
über den Tod und so weiter und und das
Leben an sich oder dieses ganz berühmte
kleine Buch ne dazu war glaube ich
damals bei mir in der Sendung was wir
gewinnen wenn wir älter werden schönes
Buch übers Alter äh der hat auch mal was
zum Thema schenken gemacht und daran
erkennst du auch ne was die Kunst des
Schenkens eigentlich bedeutet für unser
Leben und er sagt das macht das Leben
schöner und reicher denn ich zitiere
schenken macht die Seele weit und Geiz
macht sie eng und deswegen schenken
Menschen gerne
einerseits einerseits und auf der
anderen Seite stimmt das was simel
gesagt hat dass wir durch schenken auch
Menschen in unsere Abhängigkeit bringen
so das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt nur ein
Zeichen der weiten Seele
nee richtig ich erwarte dann Dankbarkeit
ne ich binde jemanden an mich genau ne
dadurch dass ich ihn beschenke ne der
der Beschenkte ist ja W wenn das
Geschenk auch noch besonders stattlich
ausfällt im Zweifel auch noch der
beschämte richtig und wenn er dann vor
dem Problem steht dass er kein
gleichwertiges Äquivalent hat wasest du
vorhin ja schon mal gesagt dieses Drama
ein paar beseschenkt sich zu Weihnachten
ja und das eine Geschenk ist also
überdimensioniert im Vergleich zu dem
anderen wobei überdimensioniert ja nicht
nur und das eigentlich noch viel
wichtiger eine Frage des Geldes ist dass
man dafür ausgegeben hat sondern die
Mühen die man darauf verwandt hat
entweder da dran zu kommen oder der
Mühen die man sich gemacht hat
Achtsamkeit achtsam it Achtsamkeit ja
dem anderen den perfekten Wunsch
abzulauschen den er nie geäußert hat mhm
man zeigt mein Gott da hat sich aber
jemand richtig Gedanken über mich
gemacht das ist ja eigentlich der
allergrößte Anteil also der tiefere
Anteil des Geschenks neben dem
materiellen Wert du WE oder spürst da
hat sich jemand mit
diramkeit ja da hat jemand aber wirklich
mal ganz genau zugehört und sich
überlegt und dann vielleicht noch alle
Hebel in Bewegung gesetzt um es zu
ermöglichen oder um da dran zu kommen ne
zum Geschenk gehört ja auch immer die
die Geschichte ja des Aufwandes den man
betrieben hat um dieses Geschenk zu
ermöglichen rich eigentlich ist das die
Geschichte ne ja finde ich ja also
jedenfalls sehr wesentlich dabei ja ja
und das das kontrastiert finde ich so
ein bisschen mit dieser Statistik die
ich auch gelesen habe zum Thema in
welche Kategorie fallen in diesem Jahr
die Weihnachtsgeschenke die Sie kaufen
wollen jetzt rate mal was mit 44% also
fast die Hälfte ganz oben ist ich weiß
es nicht aber ich weiß aus den früheren
Jahren ist es meistens unter
haltungselektronik Handy Gut gutcheine
und Geld ah ist noch schlimmer ja ja g
das hat mE das hat mein Großvater so
gemacht der hat also zum Geburtstag und
so Weihnachten
meiner Oma Geld gegeben und gesagt du
weißt ja selbst am besten was du
brauchst me ich das ist das Gegenteil
von ich habe mir Gedanken über dich
gemacht ich habe mir genau gar kein
schenken mehr in dem Sinne das ist
Erfüllung einer lästigen Pflicht richtig
eigentlich also ist eigentlich
eigentlich
eigentlich ja eigentlich ja das stimmt
also er war sonst ein großartiger Mann
aber da war ganz schlecht mhm was
umgekehrt dann häufig zu hören ist ist
du es ist egal wie viele Gedanken ich
mir mache ich mach es dir eh die Recht
das Gefühl dass viele Männer haben ja
aber das ist auch ganz schrecklich komm
beide schlecht bei Weg finde ich bei
find ich auch ja finde ich auch
interessant ist übrigens in diesem
Ranking also erst oben Gutscheine Geld
das andere Lebensmittel und süß waren
dann Spielzeug natürlich ist klar
Kleidung Bücher Kosmetika geht's immer
weiter runter dann kommst du Schmuck 15%
Unterhaltungselektronik was du eben
gesagt hast nur 9%. Bo ich hätte mal
gedacht dass WWI groß GL ich glaube ist
eine Generation Frage in der Jugend
wünscht man wir die die klassischen
Sachen von der Spielkonsole übers Handy
oder ja ich hätte ich viel höher
eingeschätzt ich ich sag das deswegen
weil ich habe mit diesen Geschenken
irgendwie so ein privates psychisches
Problem ja weil ja ich find das ja ich
finde das so unsinnlich so so
Unterhaltungs Elektronik zu verschenken
undter Weihnachtsbaum ist vielleicht
meine eigene Marotte ja also vi finde
ich unweihnachtlich irgendwie ja ja ja
ich finde auf gleicher Ebene übrigens
Einrichtungsgegenstände Schatz ich habe
dir eine schöne Spülmaschine gekauft ja
es waren so ich ich kenne wirklichute
oder wie wir als Kinder die Angst vor
den weichen Päckchen mm
ne Unterhosen Socken und solche Sachen
ja die die man als Kind wirklich nicht
auspacken will um dann nachher zu sagen
mama ich liebe dich oder so sondern wo
dann die Not Notwendigkeiten unter den
Weihnachtsbaum verlagert werden total
ich glaube das wichtigste Geschenk
meines Vaters dass ich ich wir haben
sehr wenig Geschenke bekommen und die
berühmten selbstgestrickten Socken waren
auch mal dabei wobei ich heute sagen
würde wenn mir jemand ein paar schöne
warme gbötliche Socken strickt
Wollsocken ja würde ich mich irrsinnig
freuen W ich wahnsinnig schön
weil Mühe und dann denkt er schon an
deine nächste arktische Expedition
fckt und weiter dann wei duusagen wie
viel Mühe da drin genau aber das das das
schönste Geschenk meines Vaters an mich
war ein Buch die schönsten Sagen des
klassischen Altertums das weiß ich noch
habe ich auch eins von Gustav
Schwab der K und hat mich damals
irrsinnig inspiriert war war für mich
das Buch meines Lebens hast no hast du
noch irgendwie von von den Sagen des
klassischen Altertums hattest du irgend
so eine arte Lieblingsfigur oder
Lieblingsgeschichte
m ich würde ja also ich sag mal die die
Vorgänge rund um Troja fand ich schon
immer sehr se auf Seiten der Griechen
oder auf Seiten der troelständlich nein
auf Seiten der Griechen ja tendenziell
schon ja du wollst nur auf der Seite der
Sieger stehen ich war ich habe ich habe
ein großes Herz für tragische Verlierer
deswegen sprichst du so gern mit mir
ja nein aber wenn du den großen Kampf da
zwischen Hektor und achillis we und
Achilles ist irgendwie
unverwundbar bis auf eine Stelle also es
ist so unfair und die Götter stehen ihm
auch noch bei und so weiter und die
haben ja vorher gelost die Götter steht
schon fest dass Hektor verlieren muss
und der wirft seinen Speer und der wird
dann umgeleitet von Athene um den
anderen gar nicht mehr zu treffen also
so ein fieser unfairer Kampf und so ja
und dann hat er ist der hat ja noch so
eine glückliche Liebesbeziehung ja mit
Andromache und so weiter und das ist
alles so
das geht ans Herz ja wogegen diese
archillis das ist so kampfdrohne so ein
Roboter quasi so ein Killerroboter also
ich war voll auf Seiten der Trojaner das
alles so traurig und dann werden die
noch gewarnt vor diesem dämlichen Pferd
da und so weiter auf Kassandra wird
nicht gehört und Laokoon ja der Priester
der gewarnt hat von den Schlangen die
aus dem Meer kommen wird er da drosselt
gruselig das Ganze also man kann nur für
die Trojaner sein man hat kein Herz wenn
man auf Seite der wird mal besser hier
ich ich werde mich jetzt nicht nicht für
für meine Leidenschaft in meiner Jugend
da entschuldigen ich ich fand ich fand
immer viel faszinierender wie
unvorstellbar korrupt diese ganzen
griechischen Götter waren das fand ich
so schön das das Gottesbild das uns da
zu Hause auf dem Berg vermittelt wurde
war ja moralisch makellos Jesus der
Heilige Geist Maria alle alle moralisch
makellos
Josef dann hast du da mit roten Ohren
gesessen und hast ja diese diese
lasterhaften Götter der alten Griechen
reingezogen diese
Frauenverführer Lügner und betrü und so
weiter ich f das total faszinierend weil
es war halt etwas was so ganz anders war
als die Welt in der ich zu Hause war ne
das war das ganze Ding ach so ich dachte
du hättest jetzt gedacht es wäre so
gewesen wie die wirkliche wel g Z chr
nicht nein das war ja wirklich so ein
bisschen schöne heile Welt und und für
mich ist Weihnachten um jetzt noch mal
dazu zurückzukehren das vor allen
anderen weihnachten ist für mich vor
allen Dingen ein Gefühl ja und es ist
dieses die Sonne steht so tief und sie
geht seh spät auf und dafür geht sie
auch früher wieder unter und so also
auch die Sonne arbeitet nicht so richtig
viel an Weihnachten und es wird alles
wird so still und es wird leise und es
wird ruhig und so und das ist das was
ich an Weihnachten mag und für mich hat
das immer so unfassbar hart kontrastiert
zu diesem ja wirklichen
Weihnachtswahnsinn geschenkekoller
Konsumterror den ich dann in den großen
Städten erlebt habe und der Satz du in
diesem Jahr schenken wir uns nichts ne
den habe auch ich
häufig unvorsichtigerweise ausgesprochen
um dann unterm Weihnachtsbaum die
tödliche Überraschung zu erleben wie
jetzt du hast das wirklich ernst gemeint
dachte ja also schon wenn wir uns das
gegenseitig ich find das nicht gut nee
man sollte sich was schenken ja ja ja ja
ja und wenn
selbstgebastelt das andere das andere
ich hab keine Lust mir um dich Gedanken
zu machen das steckt da doch irgendwie
bleibt das da drin hast du eigentlich wo
Du gerade erzählst da von deinen
Kindheits weihnachtsgefühlen hast du ein
Lieblings Weihnachtslied
ich mag bis heute
tatsächlich leise rieselt der Schnee und
shakin Stevens Merry Christmas to
everyone das hat sowas beschwinktes
etwas etwas leicht unseriöses auch das
mag ich okay also ein Klassiker und ein
moderner Klassiker ja kennst du Stevens
ja kenne ich kenne
ich Tochter Zion fand ich toll als Kind
ja aber das ist ja dann schon richtig
Chor das ist ja dann richtig vor allen
ehrlich gesagt Marschmusik ist
eigentlich Militärmusik Mar eigentlich
ja eigentlich eigentlich ne ne ne nicht
ursprünglich vom Sound ja ja finde ich
schon nein ein bisschen also aber egal
ich mochte es trotzdem ich fand es war
unheimlich zum sich also man schraubt
sich in dem Lied so
hoch ja schon schön schon schön ich mag
alles das diese ganzen Rituale alles was
damit Weihnachten zusammenhängt mag ich
wirklich sehr was ich ja interessant
finde ist dass die die ähm äh Wurzeln
von Weihnachten liegen ja in
vorchristlicher Zeit ne also die die rau
und weihnächte waren sozusagen Nächte
des Geister und gespensterglaubens ja
also man ne die also in den Kindern die
auf die Welt kommen erkennt man quasi
die Wiedergänger derer die gestorben
sind und beschenkt sie sozusagen
stellvertretend also die Kinder kriegen
dann Geschenke um diese Geister gütig zu
stimmen das sagen kultursoziologen zu
Weihnachten das ist interessant und dann
im Mittelalter wird der Nikolaus immer
beliebter und der bringt dann am am 6
Dezember schon die Geschenke das war
auch in der in der katholischen Kirche
war das so ne lange Zeit 6 Dezember war
der Tag also bis in die Generation
unserer Ururgroßeltern oder Urgroßeltern
waren war Nikolaus und gab's in einigen
Regionen in Deutsch glaube ich auch und
in Europa hat das sich auch sehr sehr
lange so gehalten dass der eigentliche
beschenktag ist genau und dann kommt
Martin Luther weil er die Popularität
vom Nikolaus irgendwie nervig findet ja
und er findet quasi das das Geschenk
bringende Christkind und dann kommt
Coca-Cola und dann kommt ja und den
Weihnachtsmann ja der kommt noch später
ne ja aber wie ist es bei euch gewesen
bei euch wird doch als guter Katholik
das Christkind ne bei US kam der
Weihnachtsmann also meine Eltern
protestantisch mhm da gab's kein
Christkind die fanden das Christkind
kitschig aber ich als Kind hab nie
verstanden wo der Unterschied zwischen
Nikolaus und Weihnachtsmann liegt ja das
weil die gleichen Coca-Cola Typen ne
also diese gleichen den roten mäneln was
ich noch nicht mit Coca-Cola
zusammengebracht
habe aber dass dann so vom Kaufhof einer
steht
und und sagt vom Himmel hoch da komme
ich her und verteilt
irgendwiehauf guck mal das gehört zu den
traurigen Dingen in diesem gibt's auch
nicht mehr Kaufhof sterben ja selbst den
Kaufhof gibt's nicht mehr ja wirklich ja
es ist ein hartes Jahr gewesen muss man
mal sagen an dem Punkt auch für den
Weihnachtsmann und den Mann im
Weihnachtsmann Kostüm vor dem Kaufhof
das stimmt das stimmt der Klassiker
lorio ich bin Student suchen Sie noch
einen Weihnachtsmann kennst du auch
ne Ferienjob den ich nie gemacht habe
eigentlich fällt mir weinachsmann nee
war ich auch nie aber bei uns gab's auch
kein Bedarf hätte ich aber gerne gemacht
glaube ich eine Rolle die mir gelegen
hätte glaube ich aber t so ist das mal
kann ich alles mitnehmen in diesem da
sein nee nee ne nee ne we Weihnachtsmann
übrigens unter den modernen Klassiker
nach wie vor rolling home for Christmas
m Chris reia Chris reia ja sch so dieses
dem Schneetreiben mit dem Auto schon und
so ja das das das das hat was oder ja
total ich ich äh wünsche mir sofort dass
der Sommer kommt wenn Mari carie anfängt
zu singen das halte ich nicht mehr aus
ich auch nicht ich auch nicht das
überschätzteste moderne
Weihnachtsklassiker ich ich kann ich
kann das Geschrei von Mar carry ohin
nicht hören und ich finde ich finde auch
nichts an dem Lied gut aber wenn du mir
endgültig jegliche Weihnachtsstimmung
austreiben willst dann kommt Felice
navidat das kannst du das kannst du in
Rio zum Karneval Spielen von der Musik
es ist so unfeierlich und so
unbesinnlich und was weiß ich was nee so
Köln passt Hal eigentlich nicht ist Sowi
so ein brasilianischer Karneval Schlager
ja also das kriegst du einmal im Kopf
kriegst du natürlich nicht mehr raus
aber das ist doch antiweihnachtsgefühl
das hat doch nichts mit Weihnachten zu
tun dieses Lied ich habe jetzt nicht
nachgeguckt was die Ursprünge dieses
Liedes sind aber ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass das ursprünglich mE ein
Weihnachtslied war mhm ja Mar ich ich
habe bei Mari carie immer das Thema weil
ich Maria carry ist du sagst das
Geschrei ich finde es kein Geschrei
natürlich eine großartige Sängerin das
Problem ist sie muss es in jeder
einzelnen Zeile zeigen dass sie die
großartigste Sängerin aller Zeit ist
aber zurück zu Geschenken auch in der
Politik ne Geschenke erinnerst du dich
das Antrittsgeschenk von Angela Merkel
2006 in Moskau was kriegt die von Putin
geschenkt ne das weiß ich nicht pass auf
einen schwarzweißen Plüschhund erinnerst
du dich an diese berühmte Szene Angela
Merkel Putin beide sitzen sie da und
dann kommt sein Hund rein dieser
schwarze was ist das so ein Labrador
glaube ich war das und und geht dann so
zu ihr rüber und er dann dieser
linkische Blick um mal zu gucken wie sie
reagiert die Botschaft dieses Geschenks
war klar und eindeutig wir kennen deine
Schwächen Angela Merkel hat Angst vor
Hunden dies Ende der 90er glaube ich mal
von einem Jagdhund beim Fahrradfahren
gebissen worden ins Knie und du meinst
dass die Interpretation ist er wollte
ihr Angst machen mit dem plüchhund er
könnte ihr doch auch gesagt haben wir
sind ein Hund vor dem du keine Angst
haben musst wir sind lieb und weich und
aus Plüsch ja aber wenn du das mal
zusammenbringst mit dieser Szene diese
berühmte Szene kann man sich auch
jederzeit überall angucken wo dieser
Hund da plötzlich reingeführt wird und
du siehst Ihr körperliches Unbehagen
dann verstehst du das spielt jemand ganz
bewusst mit einer Schwäche mit einer
Angst ganz ganz klar und ich glaube ich
meine ein ehemaliger kg Gegenteil sein
das kann die Versöhnungsgeste für ihre
Angst vor seinem Hund gewesen sein
bestimmt also jedenfalls öffnet es ein
großen Spielraum was hat denn Angela
Merkel Putin geschenkt oder bringt man
da keine gegen Gabe mit ich wusste
überhaupt nicht dass bei bei
staatsantrittsbesuchen solche Geschenke
ausgetauscht wden ja ich mE du kennst
doch die pand diipomatie ne die die
Chinesen beh schm heut Schmidt damals
zwei Pandas gekriegt hat und damit einen
Krieg unter deutschen zdirektoren
entfacht hat weil die Frage W welcher zo
kriegt ih das Berliner zo hat ihn damals
gekriegt also zum zum großen Groll aller
anderen zodirektoren ja und dann also
das hat zwar den Deutsch chinesischen
Freundschaft genutzt aber nicht der
Freundschaft der zodirektoren
untereinander ja ja so ist das machst du
mal ein richtig großes gutes Geschenk
und schon gibt's wieder Ärger ja das ist
wahrau aber es ist es sind interessant
ne mit pand diipomatie ist ja ganz
berühmt ne ich meine die die die
Chinesen machen seit seit seit
seit Kaiserzeiten machen die genau mit
mit Pandas machen die Politik knallharte
Interessen und wer ein Panda kriegt der
ist sozusagen etwas ganz Besonderes das
sie eindeutig die Botschaft ne ist
interessant der schade dass wir in
Deutschland keine Tiere haben die wir
verschenken können die so eine Botschaft
haben ja was sollen wir den verschenken
also was gibt's in unseren heimischen
Wäldern oder sowas ein schönen Dackel
schönen Schäferhund Dackel diipomatie
Schäferhund ist ja auch eher so Tier vor
dem sich viele fürchten P ist ja der
Inbegriff der Harmlosigkeit es muss ja
schon sowas ganz flauschiges sein wo
keine Angst vor hat und wo die sagt guck
mal ja wir sind ganz süß wir wollen nch
spielen so wie die Chinesen ja ja die
die ägüpter haben wir Giraffen
verschenkt um um irgendwie Wohlwollen zu
erzeugen oh ja das stimmt das stimmt war
damals nach Wien gekommen so girffen ich
meine genau die damals Giraffe genannt
wurde ja das stimmt ja was einige
Österreicher bis heute
sagenirafen ja girirafen genau du warum
nicht ich ich mag das alles diese Idiome
finde ich finde ich großartig der
japanische Ministerpräsident hat dem
Putin übrigens mal einen Roboterhund
geschenkt und zwar mit dem Namen
puti und der wenn er gestreichelt wurde
dieser Roboterhund bälte die russische
Nationalhymne und das hatten die Japaner
programmiert um zu zeigen dass sie in
der bei bei Robotern haushoch überlegen
sind oder siehst du und das meine ich
doch wie interpretiert er jetzt dieses
Geschenk ist das eigentlich eine
Beleidigung oder ist das einfach nur
nett gemeint hast du schon mal Geschenke
gekriegt die du als Beleidigung
empfunden hast es waren so wenige oder
eine Beleidigung deines Geschmacks
vielleicht nee ich ich bin tatsächlich
ich ich mache mir nicht besonders viel
aus Geschenken ich freue mich über
Geschenke von Kinder freue ich mich
wahnsinnig und zwar wahnsinnig gerne
wenn handgeschrieben und Hand gemalt und
so das das geht mir wirklich dann nah
ansonsten bin ich bin ich jemand der ich
bin da eher so wunschlos wunschlos und
dann auch also gehst zu den Leuten die
deutlich lieber schenken als beschenkt
werden ja und ich und ich ich
ähm diese Psychologie des Schenkens die
ist mir durchaus klar und ich glaube das
entscheidend wichtig ist ist sozusagen
wirklich nicht nur als als
ja als als als etwas was man sagt
sondern auch etwas was man dann auch so
vermittelt dass es auch wirklich
gefühlsmäßig verstanden wird ich erwarte
dann aber auch kein Gegengeschenk weißt
du ich freue mich wenn sich jemand
Gedanken über mich gemacht hat und mir
ein schönes Paar Schuhe schenkt oder was
auch immer freue ich mich wirklich wenn
ich denke ah genau die brauche ich auf
die habe ich lang gewartet
aber ich erwarte meinerseits wenn ich
etwas verschenke kein Gegengeschenk und
ich es fällt mir war schwer und das
merkst Du immer da kommt wieder diese
Abhängigkeit ins Spiel von der du redest
ne da gibt's plötzlich einen Vorsprung
den man sich er arbeitet den der andere
niemals aufholen kann und wie löst man
diesen Konflikt auf das ist echt nicht
einfach ich habe da von meiner Mutter
viel gelernt dies bezüglich meine Mutter
kannst du D du hast ja gerade gesagt du
kannst dich an das Geschenk mit den
Sagen des klassischen Altertums erinnern
hast du sonst noch weitreichende
Erinnerung Shia Shia das war das ganze
Ding die Maker Bindung und die rossin
Shia S sationell und das waren die
rennschier ich hatte dann noch
trainingsschier das waren so billigchier
und dann bekam ich irgendwann rennschier
zu Weihnachten das war mein schönstes
Weihnachtsgeschenk V von meinem Vater
hat er sich ewig lange vom mundter
abgespart und ich habe dann auf diesen
rennschieren dann mehrfach den dritten
Platz errungen reichte nie für Platz 1
aber öfter mal auf Platz 3 und da da
weiß ich noch der eine Rennleiter sagte
dann irgendwann mal zu mir nachdem ich
da durchs Ziel geschossen war du bist
aber ein schneller
Pfarrer sehr interessant dieses Bild vom
schnellen Kaplan sagt er der ein
schneller Kaplan das hat mir gut
gefallen ja aber das das war eigentlich
mein mein spektakulärstes Geschenk und
ich schenken ist nicht einfach Joel
Waldvogel ist so ein so ein ja ein
Ökonom ja ein harter Kritiker von
Weihnachten ein weihnachtsforscher wenn
man so will der sagt Weihnachten ist
eine einzige Orgie der Wertvernichtung
der hat mal ein Buch geschrieben ich
glaube ist um die um die zweehner Jahre
rum
mit dem Titel warum sie diesmal wirklich
keine Weihnachtsgeschenke kaufen sollten
ja und und zwar deswegen weil er sagt
die die die Amerikaner haben z.B 2007
Geschenke im Wert von ungefähr 66
Milliarden Dollar gekauft ja haben damit
aber nur eine Zufriedenheit erzeugt die
um 12 Milliarden ungefähr weniger war
als es mit dieser Summe möglich gewesen
wäre hat man sowas ausg auf der hat ein
Test ein Versuch macht gesagt du pass
auf wie viel ist denn das ungefähr wert
und was Du gerade geschenkt bekommen
hast und dann haben die Leute einen
Preis genannt und es kam raus im Schnitt
haben sie dem Geschenk ungefähr nur
84% des Wertes beigemessen der
tatsächlich dahinter stand der gefühlte
wert war sozusagen deutlich geringer als
der kaufpreisau das heißt er sagt die
haben jetzt 66 Milliarden ausgegeben
haben aber um rechnerisch und ökonomisch
um 12 Milliarden weniger Zufriedenheit
erzeugt und er sagt wenn es ein
Regierungsprogramm gäbe ne
durch das auf diese Art und Weise Geld
verschleudert werden würde dann werden
die Leute zurecht stinksauer mhm be
maximal ineffizient das finde ich Wiig
aus Perspektive betrachtet sind
natürlich sehr sehr viele Tausch und
austauschgeschäfte insuffizient ne aber
man darf ja eben nicht vergessen ne was
wir ja wiederholt betont haben ist es
ist beim Schenken ja eben nicht nur um
die quate Zufriedenheit im Sinne einer
gleichwertigen materiellen Entlohnung
für das was man seinerseits geschenkt
hat geht sondern dass eben dieser ganze
Mühen und Aufwand und ach und da hast du
dir Gedanken gemacht und daran hast du
gedacht und so weiter dass das ja das
eigentliche ist was man verschenkt ne
wobei ich auch in die Kategorie der der
Leute gehöre die deutlich lieber
schenken als bchenkt werden weil es sich
ja immer die Frage stellt was ist im
Fall des Falles dass jemand sich wirk
ich jetzt ganz viel Mühe und Aufwand und
alles gegeben hat und der liegt völlig
daneben das ist ja die wirkliche Tragik
also die Tragik ist ja
nicht das lieblose Geschenk was man
bekommt das was anderes ne das gibt es
ja auch und gelegentlich schon mal oder
sowas es gibt ja auch dieses rein
symbolische Geschenk man hat irgendwo
ein Auftritt gehabt und dann kriegt man
ein Geschenk weiß du als als Zeichen und
so ne da geht's jetzt nicht darum dass
das eins zu eins den Geschmack trifft
das ist ja nicht bei jedem Geschenk
wichtig aber genauer man jemand kennt
und je intimer die Situation ist umso
wichtiger ist ja schon dass man ungefähr
die Sache trifft weil sonst passiert es
dass man das ganz lieb und rührend
findet aber denkt oh Gott was mache ich
denn jetzt damit genau ich finde ja der
der der Waldvogel ja der
weihnachtsforscher hat gleichzeitig was
total gutes gesagt und wenn man diese
beiden Regeln sozusagen als Maßstab
dafür nimmt ob ein Geschenk funktioniert
oder nicht dann stellst du fest wenn du
es mal gedanklich durchgehst so so könn
es funktionieren da bist Du fast immer
auf der richtigen Seite er sagt wir
sollten auf Geschenke ganz verzichten
mit zwei ausnahen und zwar Geschenke der
Suche so nennt er das also nach dem
Motto habe ich mir immer schon gewünscht
aber nie gefunden dann triffst du bei
dem Beschenkten immer voll ins Schwarze
oder Geschenke der Erlaubnis nennt er
sie so nach dem Motto sowas habe ich mir
immer schon gewünscht habe ich mir aber
nie gegönnt wollte ich mir nie leisten
ja und das finde ich ein schönen
Gedanken ne habe ich mir immer schon
gewüncht aber nie und der Erlaubnis
genau habe ich mir immer schon gewünscht
aber nie gegönnt sie deswegen ist es ja
doch gut wenn jeder das jetzt beherzig
dann spricht er doch ganz viel für das
Schenken und wir können froh sein dass
ich damals die Puritaner ja
1647 ja in England Schottland Wales und
Irland nicht dauerhaft durchgesetzt
haben die ja das Weihnachtsfest verboten
haben
weil weil Rausch der Gefühle ja also die
die Puritaner waren ja extrem
spaßbefreit und Weihnachten soll ja auch
etwas sein ja wo man mal nichtmäßigung
mal nicht ja man istst zu viel man
trinkt
viel ja man man beschwingt sich
gegenseitig oder wie in bei vielen
weihnachtszusammenkümpfen man provoziert
sich wechselseitig bis so geht nicht
mehr wenn man auf zu engem Raum auf
Menschen trifft mit denen man leider
verwandt ist aber wie dem auch sei
jedenfalls entsteht da leicht
irgendetwas rauschmäßiges Hof für dich d
deine Verwandtschaft diese Ausgabe erst
nach dem 24 ja also so viel
Verwandtschaft habe ich ja gar nicht und
das kommt auch nicht Weihnachten zu
gigantischen verwandtschaftstreffen aber
mein Freundes und Bekanntenkreis ist
durchaus damit
gespickt dass man Weihnachten dadurch
bestraft wird Zeit mit Geschwistern zu
verbringen die man ungerne sieht und
schon gar nicht gerne
weihnachtenemin aber wie dem auch sei
also die haben das ja damals wirklich
und dann gab es ja Aufstände dagegen ja
es gab Unruh m ja also das Verbot
Weihnachten zu feiern hat den Menschen
damals im 17 Jahrhundert richtig
gigantisch was ausgemacht und was hat
man dann gemacht illegale
Weihnachtsfeiern das war so ziviler
ehusam genau genau wie die Prohibition
illegale Weihnachtsfeiern ne es gab also
handfeste Auseinandersetzung zwischen
der Obrigkeit und der einfachen
Bevölkerung wegen des abhaltens
illegaler Weihnachts feiern super und äh
der Historiker äh führt den zweiten
englischen Bürgerkrieg unter anderem auf
diese Auseinandersetzung zurück das ist
ja irre ja also zwischen Obrigkeit und
den illegal weihnachtsfeiernden die
damit natürlich auch ihre Trotzhaltung
gegenüber der Regierung zum Ausdruck
gebracht haben ja aber ich meine
eigentlich kann man sich das König K der
er ich will nicht sagen könnte noch
leben aber hätte alt werden können ja
der daingerichtet wurde im zweiten
englischen Bürgerkrieg äh wenn man
vorher die Weihnachtsfeiern verboten
hätte das heißt im Grunde war ja wenn
man sich jetzt mal ganz kurz mal so in
die englische Psyche versetzt also wenn
du sagst Weihnachten ist der Vorwand um
sich richtig die Kante zu geben und dann
verbietest du das kannst natürlich
vorstellen wie der wie der engländ da
drauf reagiert ja so wie der Kölner auf
dem karnevalsverbot so gibt dem kein
Kölsch dann wird's ganz ganz schwierig
und man versteht's ja auch oder es muss
doch diesen Moment auch mal der Erlösung
geben am Ende eines langen harten Jahres
du Erlösung mit voll Rausch gleich hab
ich das verstanden jetzt nicht in einem
theologischen Sinne ja nicht dass jetzt
wieder
die die die die katholische Kirche bei
mir anruft aber aber du weißt was ich
meine diese Moment wo man sagt komm
jetzt lass wir mal einfach mal alle
gerade sein und jetzt ist auch verpfeif
auf die Diät und auf die Disziplin ab
jetzt und heute nur noch heiß und fettig
so ich würde auch eher sagen D also bei
Weihnachten ist doch eigentlich eher die
Gefahr dass man kulinarisch über die
Stränge schlägt mm also ich weiß immer
der Klassiker ist doch immer ein paar
Tage nach Weihnachten irgendwie über
Bewegungsmangel ne und über zu viel
gutes Essen auf engem Raum man sich
darüber beschwert genau ne und und eher
etwas seltener über exzessive
Besäufnisse weißt du was ich was ich was
ich so in meiner Jugend mochte als man
ähm verändert Weihnachten sich ja ne
also Weihnachten der Kindheit ist ja
noch mal was anderes als Weihnachten in
der Jugend und meine Eltern sind dann
die die kleineschwister waren im Bett
und dann sind meine Eltern mit meiner
gleich alten Schwester und mir
noch spazieren gegangen ja und dann
guckt man so bei den anderen Leuten in
die
Stuben weiß du du kriegst sozusagen du
gehst also ist kaum ein Mensch auf der
Straße und dann so in die beleuchteten
Stuben zu gucken und sich ungefähr
vorzustellen bei dem kleinen Ausschnitt
den man so sieht wie da wohl gerade das
Weihnachten ist mhm ja also so ein
weihnachtsvjurismus ja aber in aber in
andächtig
ja und ich finde das kann man nie besser
machen als zu vorgerückter Stunde Heilig
Abend schön ja also das war das ist
jetzt nicht sozusagen die die
romantischste alle meiner
weihnachtserinnerungen aber es war so
ein Versuch wie man ja so über ein
zweiten Bildungsweg sich die
Weihnachtsstimmung der anderen ins
eigene Herz holen ja
schön sag dein schönstes
Weihnachtsgeschenk Richard schönste
könnte ich jetzt nicht sagen aber ich
habe irgendwie staunlich intensive
Erinnerungen an das Weihnachten als ich
sieben war ich habe ja im Dezember
Geburtstag da Fall fallt fallen fallen
ja erst Geburtstag und Weihnachten so
fast aufeinander und meine Großeltern
kamen immer die ich heiß und innig
geliebt habe das war natürlich besonders
schön aber ich kann mich z.B an alle
Geschenke dieses
Weihnachten mit sieben erinnern ach ja
und das da war ja weil die auch völlig
ins Schwarze getroffen haben ich habe
meinen ersten präparierten Vogel
bekommen ne was was ner sich so wünschen
ich hat ich mir auch gewünscht ich
weiblichen
Turmfalken der darf ich wer hat wer hat
den Geschossen für dich nee der wurde
nicht geschossen den haben meine Eltern
in Hannover bei einem Präparator gekauft
okay ja und der hing dann plötzlich
angenagelt da an unsere Schiebetür im
Wohnzimmer und das fand ich eich ganz
ganz toll und ich habe ein Puzzle
bekommen ich habe das Kind sehr gern
gepuzzelt und ich habe ein 1500 ilussel
was ein für ein siebenjährigen schon
eine ziemlich gewaltige Hausnummer ist
gekriegt und
zwar gab's diese wunderschönen
Ravensburger Puzzle die wurden dann
Tradition ich habe dann jedes Jahr von
da an eins bekommen und auf dem ersten
das Schönste das hieß das Geleit der
Könige stand da dran der eigentliche
Titel ist der Zug der Magier das ist ein
Gemälde von benotzo gotzuli aus dem 15
Jahrhundert und das finde ich so schön
das ist sogar das Cover später einer
meiner Bücher geworden weil das war für
mich Weihnachts immung pur schön ja das
zeigt in ein
Festumzug äh durch den
apenin bezieht sich auf eine historische
Situation aber die medicii und ihr
Gefolge sind also quasi als heilige
Könige gewandelt mhm die sind
tatsächlich haben die heilige Königs
feiern gemacht und haben sich
tatsächlich in vollem Ornat da zur prach
gestellt aber natürlich nicht in den
apeninbergen sondern das haben die
in Florenz zu Hause gemacht aber dieser
Maler hat diese Szene also verbunden mit
zu einem berühmten konzilszug und dann
schrauben die sich da durch die Berge in
so festlichem Ornat und während man das
puzzelt kommt man dem ganz ganz nahe
also jedem kleinen federbäumchen was da
gemalt ist aber auch jedes einzelne
Gesicht und ich habe mir natürlich mit
der ganzen Fantasie eine 7 8 zehjährigen
immer überlegt wer ist wer wer wäre man
gern gewesen wie gehören die und die zu
diesen anderen dazu und für mich ist
dieses Bild dass also die der Zug der
Magier von gotzuli immer noch so das
religiöseste Bild was ich kenne ja also
von die ganze Weihnachtsstimmung der
Welt ist für mich in diesem einen Bild
interess und von da an gab es das haben
wir dann alle gemeinsam gepusselt und
das ist so schön weißt du jeder ist in
seinem eigenen Segment wenn er gemeinsam
puzzelt aber alle setzen gleichzeitig
dieses Bild zusammen ja schön das ist so
so so eine wunderschöne Mischung von in
seinem eigenen Film zu sein und damit
gleichzeitig einen gemeinsamen Film zu
drehen und auch das Puzzeln ist
mit Weihnachten verbunden und ich weiß
dass meine Mutter z.B immer noch zu
Weihnachten solche Puzzel macht ach
schön abschließend Richard schönste
Weihnachtsgeschichte also ich finde die
die schönste Weihnachtsgeschichte ist
diese wunderbare sehr sehr berühmte
Geschichte von O Henry das Geschenk der
Weisen das Geschenk der Weisen ja the
gift of the Magi ja genau also Jim
undeller ne junges Ehepaar sehr verliebt
sehr arm kein Geld für
Weihnachtsgeschenke
besitzen zwei wertvolle Dinge allerdings
jim hat eine kostbare Taschenuhr geerbt
und sie hat sehr schönes langes Haar was
runterfällt bis zu den Knien genau so
und dann beschließt sie ihren Mann eine
teure Kette für seine Taschenuhr zu
schenken und dafür ihr Haar zu verkaufen
abzuschneiden und gleichzeitig verkauft
er seine Uhr um ihr ein
juwelenverziertes kamampset aus
schildpad zu schenken ja und am Tag der
Bescherung erkennen sie beide dass diese
ges kein Sinn mehr ergebenig sinnlos
geworden sind durch das Geschenk was man
dem anderen gemacht hat genau und jetzt
würde man
sagen wie kann wie kann man dermaßen
heute würde einen Epic Fail hinlegen
aber der Autor sagt ihre Geschenke
besaßen den Zauber der höher ist als
alle Vernunft ja sogar als alle Weisheit
nämlich den Zauber der Liebe ja sist
also wenn man bereit war das was einem
am aller allerliebsten ist einem weniger
wert ist als den anderen mit dem zu
beschenken was ihm am allerliebsten ist
kann man ja einen größeren Liebesbeweis
gar nicht bringen also sie bleiben mit
nutzlosen Dingen zurück ja aber mit der
mit der innigsten Versicherung einer
wechselseitigen Liebe die man sich
überhaupt vorstellen kann und
das ist eine ganz großartige Geschichte
eines quasi unbekannten Autors mhm die
Geschichte die ist damals in
amerikanischen Zeitung erschienen
1905 und er hat auch nicht mehr viel
davon
gehabt dass es eine der berühmtesten
Weihnachtsgeschichten überhaupt wurde
weil er schon 1910 gestorben ist und
abgedruckt ist sie in einem Buch das
heißt V Million ja also 4 Millionen und
das war die damalige Einwohnerzahl von
New York WoW und dieser Erzählband
besteht aus lauter Geschichten die in
den unterprivilegierten milies spielen
ne also die Seite von New York zeigen
die sonst normalerweise in der Literatur
eben nicht besprochen worden ist ja ja
also sozusagen die kleinen tragischen
und komischen Schicksale ganz ganz ganz
einfacher oder armer Leute schöne
Geschichte ne das so eine
Bedingungslosigkeit drin und so eine so
eine so eine so eine so eine Konsequenz
die die sozusagen nicht fragt was bringt
mir das ne genau und ich glaube deswegen
kontrastiert ihr auch häufig zumindest
gefühlt mit mit der Welt in der wir so
leben ne wir haben von über
geschenkorgien gesprochen ich glaube
aber dass es so gar nicht ist das wird
zwar oft so beschrieben und dann sieht
man diese Statistiken sich an und seht
oh meine Güte jetzt 123 Milliarden nur
die Deutschen in diesem Jahr aber die
Haltung die dahinter ist ja die wird ja
nicht transportiert durch diese
Statistik vielleicht ist ein guter Teil
davon genauso gemeint und atmet genau
den Geist über den wir gerade gesprochen
haben das kann ja
sein also ich finde es gibt sehr sehr
gute Gründe dem Beispiel der Puritaner
von 16 147 nicht zu folgen also ich bin
ich bin nach wie vor froh und dankbar
darum dass es Weihnachten gibt absolut
ja wunderbar schenken macht die Seele
weit Geiz macht sie eng Wilhelm Schmied
Richard ich danke Dir sehr schöne
Weihnachten dir ja wünsche ich dir auch
und grüß deine Verwandten von mir wenn
sie dann kommen an heilpan fröhliche
weihnach in diesem Sinne
tschüss eine Produktion von mhoch2 und
podstars bei R im Auftrag des
[Musik]
ZDF